clean your clothes in the future by
simply dropping this electrostatic
spherical washing machine into your
laundry basket and this new vibrating
pill has a tiny motor that begins
vibrating six to eight hours after being
consumed and it produces contractions in
the intestines that relieve chronic
constipation Vsauce Kevin here this is
mine
a Dutch designer has created wearable
technology that turns your clothes into
an mp3 player the 3d printed fabrics
that make up the bébé suit gives the
user Wi-Fi GPS and Bluetooth components
and the idea is to provide wearable as
opposed to carry Abal technology but
producing these even on a small scale is
difficult right now especially due to
questions regarding durability and
washing Scio is a pocket molecular
sensor that can detect the chemical
makeup of objects use it to get
nutritional facts about food analyze
soil authenticate medications see how
ripe an avocado is through the skin or
know which watermelon is sweeter
spectrometer technology isn't new but
shrinking went down to the palm of your
hand is and it could allow us to build a
database of matter professor Scott white
and his team have developed self-healing
and regenerating plastic in the past
self-healing and regenerating materials
were only able to fix small damages but
this new technology has the ability to
fill in large cracks and holes the
future of this breakthrough has a range
of applications including a car bumper
repairing itself within minutes of an
accident
clever pet is a Wi-Fi connected feeding
dish that teaches and entertains your
dog while you're away your dog learns
how to play with clever pet by hitting
different buttons to receive treats and
as the dog learns the challenges get
harder it's basically like video games
for dogs the hive in is a hotel concept
from Hong Kong where the rooms are built
out of shipping containers and that's
now a thing that you know mink is a 3d
printer that prints makeup it allows
users to choose any color from an image
online and turns it into a wide array of
makeup products from eyeshadow to lip
gloss because most makeup products are
created from the same basic substrates
this new technology could provide access
to any makeup at an affordable price
since many products and colors are not
available in chain stores the University
of Engineering and Technology in Peru
has created a billboard that purifies
air as efficiently as 1200 trees it
creates 100,000 cubic
years of clean air by filtering polluted
air through a water system and releasing
clean air back out to a radius of five
blocks and it's in response to the
pollution created as a result of Peru's
booming construction industry the Lix is
a pen that writes in 3d allowing you to
doodle in air it melts and cools colored
plastics as you write which creates the
rigid freestanding structures all you
have to do is plug it in for power to
heat the material as it flows through
the pen and this could lead to a whole
new way of crafting this is the world's
smallest comic that was microfabricated
with an ion beam onto a human hair so
yeah
Microsoft is developing a keyboard that
eliminates the need for a mouse the type
hover swipe has gesture control sensors
between its keys and allows you to swipe
and pinch midair to navigate through
webpages and it even claims to have
gaming functions including an invisible
steering wheel solar roadways is a
concept for replacing roads and parking
lots with a modular solar paving system
to power the world around them the
panels would be heated to keep roads
clear of ice and snow as well as smart
to alert drivers if something is in the
road the roads would be marked with LED
lights instead of painted markings and
parking lots would be able to
reconfigure parking in an instant a
researcher at the MIT Media Lab has
created super shoes a pair of flexible
soles that can be placed into any shoes
making them smart they work in
conjunction with a smartphone and can
act as a navigation device sending
vibrations in your feet telling you when
and where to turn the shoes learn your
regular patterns as well as likes and
dislikes and can navigate you through
different routes for variety or lead you
to a great restaurant you might not know
about nearby finally Technicolor Alaska
is a time-lapse capturing the Northern
Lights as seen from Alaska
I'm gonna leave you with a camouflaged
robotic snake and as always thanks for
watching